[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to chess openings
explained as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i am jumping on the beth
harmon bandwagon that's right better
late than never as someone said in the
chat
but this uh netflix limited series based
on
a book has been out for some time now
and i finally
wanted to give my take on a lot of the
chess that was featured in the show
uh that is the queen's gambit is the
name of the show and beth harmon
the name of the main character in the
show so i actually wanted to focus a lot
on beth harmon's earlier games when she
was first learning to play chess
and when she was first showing some
talent for the game
because i think it's really interesting
how they showed the
you know obviously accelerated
development of a new chess player and
especially a talented one
so to start with uh beth harmon in the
show is taught chess
by the one mr schaible who is i believe
the custodian for the orphanage where
she is maybe he's just like the general
maintenance guy
but one of those types of jobs and slash
a chess
genius it turns out so let's jump into
it beth harmon's very first game of
chess
i have right here in front of us once
again mr schreibel
takes the white pieces because he is
brutal
uh the way he teaches beth harmon is
pretty funny in the show
uh i won't you know spoil too much by
going into too much detail
but this is the first game that they
play essentially beth harmon comes down
says hey big dude i want to play some
chess
but i'm a small child and the big dude
says
fine we can play a game of chess sit
down i get white because i'm
larger than you okay so mr schreibel
plays e4
beth harmon plays the move e5 then mr
schaible being very
mean plays bishop c4 black plays the
move knight c6
and mr schreibel plays queen f3 and many
of you have probably seen
uh this game before many many times so
as
stated in the show beth harmon falls for
the checkmate with knight d4
then with the bishop supporting the
queen
we do actually get a four move checkmate
and as stated in the show
this is called the scholars mate
so to a casual viewer who doesn't play
much chess
it might seem sort of unrealistic that
you lose in four
moves or maybe that doesn't seem that
unrealistic at all
but this opening has a name for a reason
it's called
the scholars mate for a reason uh in
this case
rather than scholars mate describing you
know some type of academic scholar who
is
well-versed in chess scholar in this
case
refers namely to scholastic students
children because this uh form of
checkmate really does make a very very
common appearance
in scholastic tournaments amongst
beginner players
this is how a lot of chess games end at
the beginner level
and it's pretty clear to see why it's
sort of the fastest checkmate it only
takes four
moves that you can uh threaten by force
with with the white pieces now there are
of course very very easy ways
to get out of the checkmate uh that beth
misses
in her first game of chess uh and we'll
see that she doesn't fall for the same
thing
twice uh pretty much ever in this show
so that is her first game of chess and i
thought it was really interesting that
they decided to start with this
because i get the feeling that this is
many people's
first game of chess or at least for a
serious game of chess
if they go in a little bit unprepared as
beth unfortunately had to do
for lack of resources now uh
fortunately for us beth harmon's chess
career does not end here she decides she
wants to play again
and so i wanted to take you to the
rematch of
the century once again we have mr
scheible
uh orphanage custodian slash chess
genius against beth harmon
who is still in this game a small child
and i believe this is actually the
second game of chess they ever played
so here beth has gone gone up gone up
the stairs
back to bed she's done the prep work by
which i mean
she hallucinated a chessboard on the
ceiling she's seen all the lines
she's no longer going to fall for the
scholars mate
so perhaps the simplest way to avoid
this checkmate
is to play the move 2 or 1 rather e6
now what's the point of this move well
some people will tell you the point is
to play like frenchman
but i think in the show what they were
going for is showing that beth is
actually learning
from her first game mistake you know
despite barely understanding the rules
and having only played one game of chess
she you know being a big time
uh addict of sorts to to the game of
chess
she was hallucinating the game in in her
sleep in a sense
and had seen the way out of stopping
this devastating light squared attack
the the way to do it is to play pawn e6
uh guarding all the light squares
so now we see mr scheible uh sort of
divert chorus here no longer going for
this type of checkmate because it
doesn't work
thanks to this pawn being in the way so
we see the move d4
and now beth harmon plays g6 we see
knight f3
uh and i sort of had to piece this one
together going frame by frame because
they don't just show you only the chess
board in the show there's a lot more
going on
but i'm pretty sure beth plays queen f6
first here which is obviously a bit of a
strange move
so beth has learned from her game one
mistake
in hanging the forum move checkmate but
she still at this stage
is making very very common beginner
mistakes and this is something that i
actually haven't seen a lot of people
talking about online
online i think most people are focusing
on the games later on in the show that
are based on some famous historical
games
but i really actually enjoyed these
first couple games because they are
as well very realistic to a chess
beginner's experience
uh when playing someone who is by no
means that great at chess
in mr schreibel's chess in mr
schreibel's case but definitely has a
solid foundation of what they're doing
especially in the opening
now we see mr scheibel play the move
bishop d3 which i think pretty much fits
his character
bishop d3 may not even be the best move
but it's a pretty reasonable move that
chess amateur would make
and now we see beth unfortunately play
bishop g7
which of course loses the game so white
to move chat room who sees
how to win right away i'm sure most of
you already have this one under control
here he's janitor the janitor custodian
janitor same thing
maybe not i'm gonna get a lot of angry
janitors and a lot of angry custodians i
feel
by saying this
so of course the idea here as the chat
says is to play bishop g5
and so we see now uh although this goes
sort of unexplained in the show
we see beth sort of learning the classic
beginner mistakes
for anybody who has a chess background
right in the first game we learn about
the scholars mate
and we learn not to let that happen and
now in game two
perhaps this is showing beth learning a
little bit of basic opening principles
without being explicitly told them right
now it's clear
to beth that maybe you shouldn't bring
the queen out right away
and maybe you shouldn't weaken all of
your dark squares with your early chess
moves
now in the game beth actually takes on
g5 and
mr schaible takes on g5 and then
rather aggressively declares the game
over uh now that the queen
has been murdered so rematch of the
century didn't go so well
for beth either but uh spoiler alert
here
spoilers anybody turns out beth does get
better at chess
and starts to win so i'm going to start
showing you some of the games
where now she's learned rather at an
accelerated pace of course
but she has learned some of the basic
opening principles that we often talk
about in chess lectures
and it's really really cool to see
that in this show they decided to make
beth lose so quickly but in a rather
realistic way
right she's not making absurd moves
where she just hangs a queen
because someone who's talented at chess
might not be making those mistakes
but on the other hand she is falling for
strategic mistakes that can lose the
game very very quickly
just stuff that you sort of have to you
know experience or have to be told in
order to learn stuff that you can't
really just
fake with talent so
ah i'm told this was actually their
third game
i thought this was game two ben tells me
it's game three
there was there was a quick second game
as well well anyways game three i think
this is beth's
best attempt uh before she finally
manages it manages
to turn it around so now i have actually
labeled their names with question marks
because i want to play a little game
with the chat room this is in fact one
of the games
where the producers of the show along
with
chess consultants like gary kasparov
decided to base the the game they should
they
display in the show uh uh they decided
to base it
on a on an historical chess game so
who in the chat can tell me who actually
played this game first
before beth harmon and mr schaible and
now this game
as i've said beth did get get a bit
better unfortunately in the show
beth's first win against mr scheible
they show very very little of and i i
tried clicking around online to see if
anybody uh had posted the full game but
i was unable to find it so this is
actually beth's
second uh win against mr scheible when
he finally
deems her ready to play with the white
pieces of course mr scheible
very experienced chess player knows to
always sit down at the side of the board
that has the white pieces
for maximum advantage but all right
let's jump into it here
we of course have e4 e5 which again is
very very common for beginner chess and
of course experienced chess players
alike we see knight f3
knight c6 fairly normal stuff bishop c4
and it's the oldest opening in chess the
italian turned gioco piano
and yeah this is exactly true to how
most beginner chess games look
oftentimes beginners are told develop
out with the king's pawn
and then just develop your pieces pretty
much anywhere and more often than not
they end
up in some position that looks like this
now we do see beth
playing sort of more aggressively though
with the move c3 and this demonstrates
some understanding
i would say that if this were a pure
beginner game more often than not
you're gonna see the simple d3 kingside
castles
knight c3 and this bishop really out out
to anywhere this is how we tell
beginners
uh to play in the opening you just
really get the pieces out anywhere and
then
play play your chess game but beth
having accelerated beyond that already
decides on the move c3 which is sort of
the main variation in the italian game
mr schaible now plays a kind of strange
move but it's by no means unheard of
in the form of queen to e7
so this is a little bit of an early
queen development here and the idea is
simply to discourage the move d4
by putting a little bit of pressure on
this e4 pawn
now normally this is done by the simple
knight to f6 just immediately pressuring
this pawn on e4
but queen e7 is sort of a playable
sideline
we see beth castle which is a pretty
good response you just want to step
out of the attack on the e4 pawn and the
game continues now
with d6 going for development and now we
see
sort of the flaw with queen to e7 is
that it really only minorly
inconveniences
white no longer does beth really have to
worry about this pawn on e4
because after d4 e takes d4
is not really ever making a threat here
on the pawn
to eve on the pawn on e4 for example
even if
you know white were obliged to hang this
pawn
uh black could not capture it due to
rookie one pinning the queen to the king
so this queen e7 line maybe this is just
a
you know a blank spot in my chest
understanding but it just seems like
this line is
isn't very good after all mr scheibel
though continues playing pretty normally
e takes d4 is actually a bad move
because this is never really going
to be a threat so we see bishop back to
b6
instead and now we see a rather
interesting move
by beth harmon and that is the move
bishop to g5
this actually isn't the best move by
opening theory standards today
and the reason for that is it sort of
entices black to just develop out
normally
right usually you don't want to play a
move that forces your opponent to play a
good move
in this case knight f6 is a good move
it's a useful move for black
so there's not really a reason to force
black to play something like this
also you'll see that this bishop might
actually be a little bit endangered here
on the g5 square
and black could potentially even expand
on the king's side
noting the fact that white's king is
already castled here
and black's king is not black still has
some options to perhaps go the other way
with queen side castling or even leave
the king in the center momentarily
that being said though mr scheible in
the game unfortunately plays a
very very bad move in the form of f6
and i think this is really consistent
with the strength of the characters that
they've shown thus far
beth of course is always going to be
improving rather rapidly uh just because
that's the nature of being a child
prodigy
but mr scheible's limits have finally
been shown
he knows a couple cheap tricks he knows
what to do in the first few moves of the
opening but maybe he's not such a good
chess player after all he doesn't
know that a move like f6 is very very
weakening
and he is putting himself in great
danger so let's see how beth capitalizes
first and foremost you have to deal with
the threat to the bishop so we see
bishop back to h4
and this is a good move for a number of
reasons but mainly because
it keeps this f pawn locked right here
on f6
not allowing it to step out to f5 where
it can really contribute to the game a
bit more and allow this queen some
breathing room
and by keeping the pawn on f6 we also
make it very very difficult for this
knight to develop out as well
black though is able to continue with
this move g5
and this is sort of similar to some
stuff i was talking about with h6 in g5
so chat room how do you think beth
should respond
to this g5 push how should black
or how should white respond caesar says
morphy
moneyballin says morphy and yeah
nobody i think has the right answer yet
nobody knows
who these players are
it's not real it's acting wow here i
thought i was watching a documentary
why does everyone keep saying paul
morphy well because this game as i
said is based on an actual historic
chess game
and they are guessing who's playing
white but it is not morphy
so yeah you guys have exactly the right
idea well some of you do
bishop g3 is probably an okay move i
wouldn't think
that white is going to be any worse in
this position
black has still made a ton of weaknesses
and there's still a ton of threats that
black has to keep track of
but the winning move is in fact actually
knight takes on g5
now why is this move so good well it all
comes down to this move
of f6 the point of knight takes g5
is yes to capture this pawn but more
importantly it grants this queen
an avenue to get into the game and
without this pawn on f7 this queen is
actually coming into the game
with check and after that the weaknesses
that black has made by pushing these two
pawns forward are really going to start
to show themselves
so black in the game does decide to
capture back on g5
and then beth comes out with queen h5
check now
because these two pawns have vacated
their home positions
this is check because there's no pawn on
f7 and there's no pawn on g7 to help
block this check
this means that black is in the very
awkward position of having to do
something with this king
and king d7 is what mr scheible chooses
in the game now you don't need to do
something immediately
even though beth just sacrificed a full
piece black's position
has been weakened enough and white's
pieces are active enough that you don't
necessarily
have to immediately checkmate the
opponent in this case beth just takes on
g5
and rather than play knight f6 which
would run into
a couple moves namely just queen h4
piling up the pressure
this would have been the best way for
black to continue trying to develop
pieces
at all costs but rather than that we
actually see the move queen g7 by mr
scheible
and this move is in fact quite bad so
white to move and actually checkmate in
just a few moves
in this position see if you could find
what the young small child
beth harmon managed to find in her
second ever win
what to do here what to do
white to move and when
[Music]
youtube watcher says this is a modern
boulder blitz game
we see bobby tall steinitz cappa blanca
schlecter casablanca
all very good guesses and then there's
actually one name i didn't mention
which is the correct answer in the chat
now
[Music]
so some of you guys have it it's
actually not the move queen g4 check the
problem with this move
is black can come back right where he
came from actually
and you're not making much progress here
in fact black is actually a little bit
well a little bit better organized to
start meeting these threats on the light
squares
so the thing to do is to keep black
stuck in this mating net that's what
this is called
the black king is in a mating net
meaning
it doesn't have any escape squares all
of these squares around the king are
covered and then all of these squares
are actually covered by blackstone
pieces
so the thing to do is to find some way
to put this
king under threat without really giving
up this
net by playing queen g4 you sort of
loosen the net because the black king
has an avenue
to sort of run away but the correct move
as some in the chat have found is
actually the move bishop e6
the surprising sacrifice actually keeps
the black king stuck in the net
and even tightens it further after the
second move of queen to e8
now the net is completely titans
with absolutely every square around this
king being covered
uh and so black has no choice but to
block this check the king can't run away
as all of the squares are covered so we
see knight g to e7 in the game
and then of course the final move now
that all of the escape squares are
covered
we simply have to put this king into
check to end the game
and beth does so with pawn to d5 and
this is the end of the game for mr
scheible
and they go on to i think play a few
more games after this but that is where
i am leaving the ultimate rivalry
between beth harmon
and mr scheible and slight spoiler alert
for the show i think mr scheible
actually has the winningest record
against beth harmon uh in the entire
series so
she doesn't have a perfect run i think
but mr scheible
has proven himself to be perhaps her
toughest opponent of the series
with those two wins uh in in the
beginning so fun stuff
and as someone in the chat has now said
the correct answer for who played this
game
is the one and only uh greco
uh who has yeah the the oldest chess
games ever recorded or among some of the
oldest chess games ever recorded
not quite the oldest i think and of
course he was most known for his games
against
anonymous players i don't know all the
chess history there i think maybe he was
recording some games
and we don't know who he was playing
quite often but this is
one of the many greco versus no name
games you can find out there on the
internet
and this choice to to go back to the
1600s and start showing some of these
really fun
old old chess game wins i think is a
good one because
what you find in these old games is
someone with a really good
understanding of you know basic
combinations
calculations and in check meeting
threats right that's what the the old
people
uh in in the 1600s had pretty much
well down that's their most comparable
skill to today
their opening strategy their principles
not quite as developed
but they could calculate out a
three-move checkmate
as we see here and that's sort of what
you would expect from a beth harmon a
child prodigy with absolutely
no or very very little direction thus
far but
with this sort of raw ability to
calculate out checkmates and to find
attacking moves like this
this is sort of what you can expect from
someone who is relatively untrained
in the 1600s they were untrained because
there was just no body of theory to
learn from
in the tv show beth harmon of course uh
living in an orphanage did not really
have much to study off of so also
working
without really any body of theory so
i don't think i'm giving away too much
just some some plot lines in episode one
but after her matches against mr
scheible mr scheible starts to recognize
that hey beth harmon's pretty talented
at this board game
maybe he should call in to the the local
school's chess team
and see if she can uh make some waves
there
so mr schreibel calls in one mr
granz gronz i don't know how to say his
name
just as bad as i am with chess player
names i'm also bad with fictional chess
player names
but we'll call him mr grant's for my
american accent
uh and so mr granz is the coach of a
local chess school
and he comes in to sort of test beth
harmon's ability to see if she
can make it in the big leagues of
competitive tournament chess
and uh well i don't want to give too
much away why don't we just check out
how this
how this works out for him beth has the
white pieces once again
and starts with knight f3 and and then
we get one of the funny lines
that i've noticed in the show uh they do
a really really great job with all of
the chess
but sometimes there is some funny
dialogue that's clearly there for the
people who who don't play as much chess
uh just to sort of give them the wink
wink nod nod look look at
look at all this chess jargon we know uh
and so here mr grant's
triumphantly says ah the reti uh which
is close to the truth
it's close to the truth it's not quite
the ready yet
the ready is i think officially what
happens
after knight f3 d5 and c4 so with knight
f3
white is definitely on the way to
already but not necessarily there yet
now uh that may be different with like
the historical time and openings names
changing
i don't entirely know so maybe i'm full
of it and the show got everything right
but there is a there are a few of these
funny lines where they
they triumphantly declare some sort of
chess thing in the dialogue
and it doesn't always necessarily match
what's happening on the board
black in this case plays f5 which is
actually an opening line
i was very much unfamiliar with so
knight f3 f5
and then beth miraculously plays the
move e4 and i was
sort of stunned but by this i had never
seen anything like this
um in my chess career turns out this is
an actual gambit
that players with the white pieces have
been doing for some time now
i'm not convinced it's very good but it
is a gambit that people
do play so mr granz being the sucker
that he is
says that's a free pawn i'll take that
and then we actually see the move
knight e5 by beth and this is
really really not a good move i don't
think to the best of my research
abilities this
is based entirely on an historical chess
game
because this 95 move is sort of
so so bad so as you would expect in an
opening like the budapest gambit which
if you guys watched the intro
you should have seen some of that um
the best move is knight g5 and the point
now is that white can apply some early
pressure to this e4
pawn force black to make some kind of uh
some kind of move
that defends this pawn on e4 and then
white can continue developing out very
very quickly with the move like d3
now in the game we see beth play knight
e5 and i i think in my opinion the
showrunners did this
to arrive at an early checkmate
uh now in the game mr grands plays the
move
d5 which itself doesn't really seem to
be too bad of a move
it defends the pawn on e4 and activates
the bishop
but definitely a much better move in
this case is knight to f6
and we'll see why momentarily so we get
d5
by uh black and now white already
actually has a bit of a tactic to get
back into the game because after
95 white should definitely be worse but
after d5 there is
a path back into the game so i'm sure
many of you in the chat
and watching at home are sort of
screaming out the move queen h5 check
you've probably seen this tactic many
times before and it's similar to what we
saw
with beth's win against mr scheible
black has moved the f
pawn early weakening this diagonal and
white can try to take advantage by
activating the queen in this case though
the story is not so simple because g6
is going to block this check and now is
where the people in the chat are
probably saying
knight takes g6 and the point now is
that this is a pretty comfortable pin
on the rook on h8 so it seems like white
should just be winning
but black does have a way to stay in the
game with the the strange looking move
knight f6 rather than deal with the
threat to the rook or the threat of the
discovered check
black manages to actually develop a
peace out and attack white's queen at
the same time
white is going to be forced to move the
queen out of the way and then black can
get back into this game
by developing the rook now is black
going to be much better here
probably not because these weaknesses
are not going away
but it is at least going to be a chess
game instead
we actually see beth play what i think
is a better practical choice
now queen h5 might be objectively the
best move because it gets white into
a level position from a worse position
but d3
is sort of the more active more fun move
and it's not even that bad for white
anymore either
we see mr gronz you know being the low
level
high school chess club coach greedily
take all the material
as many low-level high school chess
coaches would
and now we see bishop takes d3 and
beth's gambit is sort of
working all according to plan here uh
rapid development
in exchange for a pawn and a very nice
looking knight on e5
highlighting some of these light squared
weaknesses in black's camp
now is sort of the last uh last chance
for black to stay in the game
you have to play the move knight f6 you
have to stop queen h5 check or else
you're just going to get rolled over
instead we see mr grant's play knight c6
and as you might expect now
uh beth harmon in in the the show
declares that it is now checkmate in
three moves and she
is absolutely correct however i've got a
bone to pick with you beth harmon
you played the wrong checkmate
in the game mr granz actually resigns
and beth just shows the checkmate on the
board
but the the shockmate that she shows is
queen h5 check
and then after g6 she undoubtedly plays
the
incorrect move as many of you in the
chat i think would agree
bishop takes g6 as shown in the show is
in fact checkmate but is definitely the
wrong checkmate
because why would you sacrifice a bishop
for checkmate
when instead you could sacrifice the
queen where
is your sense of chess aesthetics beth
harmon no excuse for this one
you don't need to study chess to know
that sacrificing queen
a queen is much cooler than sacrificing
a bishop so where's the excuse beth
harmon
why why would you sacrifice your bishop
instead of your queen i don't understand
and i will never understand uh so
this is beth's game against the high
schooler
not the high schooler the high school
chess club coach or at least
school school coach i don't know if it
was high school students exclusively
in the show or not so what is there to
learn from this game
honestly this is one of my less uh
favorite games
from beth harmon's early days because
it's a little bit strange
it's a bit of a strange game you could
expect some of these strange moves from
a beginner
but this one feels a bit more
constructed than than the other games
right one was an actual historical game
the others felt very natural in the way
that uh the the weaker side was losing
but in this case
we see black being rather compliant
right i think a lot of beginners
would like to play the move knight f6
here because if you're beyond the point
of hanging stuff like scholars mate
stuff like queen h5 check is is usually
on your radar as a chess beginner
so something like knight f6 even a move
like g6 i would have been fine with
seeing
and this is also actually quite quite a
bad move because
this leads to a different checkmate that
i want to talk about here
so my comment for the showrunners and i
think they may have seen this game
i sort of suspect with my tinfoil hat
that this game
that they constructed here may have been
based on this historical game i'm about
to show you
but i think they should have just stuck
with uh the historical game that i'm
about to show
so my claim is that they based this
rather loosely
on this game between these two random
people who i've actually never heard of
named hans haberditz against the
enigmatic heisek so in this game we
start off the same way
knight f3 f5 e4 f takes e4
but then rather than play the weird
looking move knight e5
trying to you know get to this contrived
checkmate position
i think they should have just stuck with
the main move of nate g5 i think it's a
lot more natural
and it is just a better move in this
case
d5 is a lot more reasonable to expect
because white was already applying a lot
of pressure to the d
to the e4 pawn now just as in the game
d3 is correct we could see e takes d3
bishop takes d3 and then you can even
allow black to play the good move
of knight to f6 because in this game i'm
about to show you
uh white actually achieves checkmate in
exactly the same number of moves as in
the previous game
so after knight f6 chat what extra
option does white
have here to actually claim a winning
advantage
right off the bat white to move and get
a winning advantage
what do you think what do you guys think
and yeah albert in the chat has a pretty
good idea here
so as in many of the early wins we're
examining from beth harmon
it all revolves around these light
squares
right we see beth getting a lot of free
wins because her opponent
or sometimes her herself when she loses
uh
was not attentive enough to control over
these light squares and that's going to
be
the case here again so the move knight
takes h7
i think is quite natural and in fact
does give white
some advantage uh in the game i'm
discussing here
way back in 1938 black was rather
compliant and captured this knight on h7
as you might expect and this of course
leads to checkmate after bishop g6 check
the king has nowhere to go there's no
more defenders of the light squares
around the king
king d7 and then queen takes d5 and
as in the other example this move is
checkmate so i don't know if the
showrunners had seen this game
or had just seen games like this in
order to construct the game in the show
but i think this actually may have been
a bit of a better
choice for realism in the chess game now
obviously
they have gone so much further than any
other tv show really has
with realism in there the the chess
games that they're showing but it would
have been cool
to see a game like this which does still
have
historical you know roots anyways
enough on that so uh beth you know beats
up this
this high school coach or this this
school coach local school coach
but that's not enough the the school
coach wants some more
so they play a second game uh in this
game i think beth is actually playing a
a bit of a simul against both
mr scheible and uh grant and i've
actually labeled the wrong name
as black so let me update that really
quick mr
grant's question mark
because i think this one may have also
been a historical game let me check my
notes here it is a historical game
so for their game 2 they did pick
another game
from chess history so again for those of
you at home if you want to try and
follow along
see if you can pick out which chess
players are playing in this game in
reality
then go ahead and take your guesses in
the chat but for the moment we're
sticking with beth harmon
and mr granz this game goes e4
and mr granz adopts the kero khan
in this case we have d4 d5
knight c3 rather mainline stuff by beth
harmon
d takes c4 knight takes e4
and now for those of you who aren't
familiar the idea of the carol khan for
black
is to take a slightly more conservative
approach black has less space in the
center
white has this pawn advanced further
than any other pawn on the board
granting him
or granting her in this case some extra
space but black's position is pretty
solid
tough to sort of open this position up
rather early on
we'll see compared to the other games
black actually has good control of the
light squares on the king's side and so
probably isn't going to get checkmated
quite as fast
that being said mr granz actually adopts
a very
tactical line of the kerala khan as
opposed to the more subdued main line of
bishop f5
just to show you how the game might go
here this is the mainline stuff
white can take out some extra space on
the king's side
and eventually we'll see some trades
and again we see black with this sort of
conservative
setup where black isn't taking much
space but black also isn't making too
many weaknesses
and it's going to be a long hard-fought
battle from here
uh conversely white is taking a lot of
space
and sort of going for rapid development
and is probably going to look to attack
black in the normal cairo con now
we see black mr grant in this case
actually playing this move knight to f6
and this is definitely not the main main
line of the caro khan
here black is theoretically allowing
white to trade off these knights
and double blacks pawns either with e
takes f6 or g
takes f6 in the game though we see beth
actually pulling out some novelties with
the move queen d3
this isn't by any means the most common
but it has been seen a few times
and notably as i've said this is based
on on
a historical chess game and so it's
definitely been seen before
the idea of queen d3 is to simply leave
this knight sitting
on e4 and if black gets so daring as to
trade these pieces
this queen may actually be more active
for white and not so easy to kick away
for black we know a big point of the
kerala khan is to develop out this
bishop
and it's going to be difficult to do
that with this queen sitting on
e4 in the game we actually see mr
grant's decline
to take this knight and plays the rather
in cautious move
of pawn to e5 this
is not a good move but it's not
immediately clear
why so i'm curious if those of you in
the chat can give me
a few moves long line if you're really
hardcore you can try and tell me the
rest of the game
from this position you can probably
calculate out how
you can see black get checkmated in just
a few moves
if you're really really good that is and
it does involve some guesswork
but why is e5 a mistake it might not be
as easy as some of you may think
and the chat is making fun of me for
saying the wrong pronoun i apologize i
do apologize to the fictional character
of beth harmon
so there's a couple ideas in the chat
being tossed around
[Music]
so bishop g5 in general is a pretty good
chess move and
and white has i think a very decent
position after bishop to g5
but black is in fact hanging material
here
as some people in the chat are saying d
takes e5
is in fact the correct move but i did
say
that the story might not be as simple as
you expect
on the surface it looks like black just
played an awful awful move
this pawn on e5 has no defenders and
it's attacked one time
so why not capture it for free but
mr granz or in this case and a
historical chess player
had a different idea in mind with d
takes e5
how many of you in the chat actually
spotted that queen a5 check
is playable for black and this is
actually a fork of the king
and the pawn now beth plays bishop d2
to block the check with tempo and we see
queen takes e5
so the story might not be so simple here
black seems to have regained the pawn
and activated the queen without losing
too much
but now white does in fact have a
winning combination
so white to move and win the game
wait to move here chat what do we think
what do we think
and yeah we are arriving at the rather
famous position
so as some people in the chat are
mentioning they have already guessed
the the player with the white pieces and
one person already has
the exact game with the player with the
black pieces as well
and that happens after queen side
castles
so this move rather mysteriously
seems to be hanging the knight on e4 uh
the easiest move to refute is the move
queen takes e4
when we have the classic mistake of
black leaving the king in the center
and playing with the queen in front of
it you simply go rook e1
with what's known as the pin the queen
is stuck down to the king back here on
e8
and black is going to lose the queen now
black does have
a piece and a rook for it after queen
takes e1 and bishop takes c1
but this should be a winning advantage
now that's pretty easy to spot
so mr grant's being a respectable school
chess coach does not fall for it
instead we see mr grant's with knight
takes e4
which is the harder move to refute
slightly but
as some people in the chat have already
pointed out this does
have a fatal flaw as well so go ahead
and pause here if you want to try and
find
the fun checkmate uh otherwise i'm just
going to show it here it is
queen d8 check the stellar queen
sacrifice
is played in the game king takes d8
and now bishop g5 with what's known as
double
check again beth harmon at the early age
in the show
is showing that she may not have all the
positional nuances down
but she is a tactical mastermind
double check to this king and now this
king actually only has two legal moves
you can't block this check because
you're in check from two different
directions
so against a double check you can't
capture either because again
in check from two different directions
so what you must do
is move the king now the king can only
move to e8
or c7 and it turns out that it is
actually checkmated
regardless of which square it moves to
king the e8 for example
would mean rook to d8 with a checkmate
this one you may recognize
from a certain paul morphy uh in the
opera game perhaps but king to c7
is played in this game with a different
checkmate entirely coming from bishop to
d8
when this bishop actually attacks
through this king
to stop it from going to b6 uh sort of
you know sticks this king all the way
through
uh disgusting stuff honestly and the
work defends the bishop cuts off all the
escape squares
and we see all of the black pieces sort
of playing against him
uh keeping this king stuck on c7
so beth's off to a good start now for
the mystery solvers out there i've
already seen the correct answer in the
chat
but these two players from chess history
are actually
richard reddy and tartakower back in
vienna uh
and ben is 1910 i wrote 1905. i would
trust ben's date better than mine
um so in 1910
ready against tardikower with this very
very famous chess game
that got featured in the show so cool
stuff so far
cool stuff so far uh and all of this by
the way all of these
fun historical chess games actually are
making an appearance in the very first
episode so there's a ton of chess
content to cover here
now from here beth does start to play a
little bit better
but i did want to show one more game
from what i would consider
her beginner chess era uh which is an
interesting decision
by the show runners so uh i don't want
to spoil
too much but basically episode 1 we get
to see beth as a small child getting her
beginnings
in chess and then eventually a little
bit later she's a little bit
older and has studied chess sort of on
her own
from the encyclopedia of chess openings
mco
as stated in the show so it's
interesting that at her first chess
tournament after she's had actually a
few years
to study up on her chess openings they
decide to feature
the opening shown in her next game this
game is between someone by the name of d
l towns who is a character in the show
and
he is beth's opponent in in her first
tournament
in one of the rounds at least now dll
towns seems to be
your average club level player uh who
is uh i don't know i think they like
show the pairing sheet at some point
during the show i didn't catch
his exact rating but he's a pretty
decent average
tournament player right no not like a
master or anything but a decent
tournament player
and the opening they decided to feature
for this one is actually e4
and d5 so beth
uh having moved away from playing e5 in
e6 when she was getting slaughtered
against mr schaible
now moves on to the scandinavian and
after towns actually takes on d5
we see beth playing the rather rare move
of
c6 and this is a pretty bad gambit
by beth harmon here uh gambit in this
case meaning
an early sacrifice of material now
what's so wrong about this
well you'll see in this opening towns
actually
kind of refutes beth harmon's uh opening
play here
now by refute i don't mean that that he
wins the game immediately
but he does a really good job of showing
why beth's opening play is wrong
and i thought this was a pretty
interesting decision by the show runners
here so
beth has had a few years to sort of
study mco and train up
but she still hasn't really had any type
of coach or mentor
aside from the more beginner mr scheible
early on
and so what we see here is beth playing
a very dubious opening but i think this
actually
sort of lines up with her character so
far all she's had so far are very easy
opponents
who she can just sort of slaughter with
tactical play no matter what
opening she is going for so playing a
dubious gambit i think perfectly in line
with what beth is known to do so far
uh in the game we see towns play d take
c6
and beth plays knight takes c6
uh now uh unfortunately i did have to do
some guesswork on this game because they
only showed
it sort of after a couple moves were
played but
in a sense the game went like this i
don't know if i'm getting the move order
exactly right with how they intended
but essentially towns plays this move
bishop b5
and i think this is a really critical
move to uh
to the position here with bishop b5
towns is saying
yes you got to develop your knight
essentially for free because i wasted
time
taking all your pawns but this night's
not even going to be useful i can
develop out and stop this knight from
doing any damage
sort of right away now we see beth
taking it slow
and just developing pieces with the move
pawn to e5
but town simply plays knight f3 and
already
white's pieces are working well together
and black does not even have a lead in
development
normally when you sacrifice material
early on you do it to get a lead in
development to get your pieces out more
quickly
but in this case we see that it's
actually towns with more pieces
developed with these two minor pieces
compared to black's one uh beth now goes
on to make sort of another mistake
trying to develop out quickly with
bishop to g4 maybe a bit better is the
slightly more conservative move of
bishop d6 just to make sure that this
pawn is well defended
instead we see bishop g4 and the idea of
this move
is to counter white's threat of
capturing this pawn by pinning black's
knight to the queen or white's knight to
the queen as well
towns though takes it very calmly and
plays the move knight c3
just controlling the square in front of
this pawn notably if white tried to do
something like castles
potentially a move like e4 might be a
threat probably it's not
because black has left the king in the
center but beth could perhaps play
something like queen f6
and amp up the pressure here so instead
we see knight to c3 just controlling the
square in front of the pawn
making sure no funny business happens
also supporting the bishop on b5
really really solid play by town so far
beth continues out with knight f6
and then we see towns make a really
interesting decision that's
uh is actually quite a good one and that
decision is to actually just capture
this knight on c6
rather unprovoked so what does this do
well it takes away
a pretty strong attacking piece that
black could have used to step into d4
and further attack the this pinned
knight it also
fractures black's pawn structure on the
queen side sort of cementing a really
solid advantage
both in material with wiping up upon and
in the structure of
the the pawns with these two pawns being
isolated unable to defend each other
whereas white's pawns of course are
still able to defend each other
at a moment's notice now the show
actually cuts from the game here and
starts showing it much later on
and as this is an openings class i don't
really want to go through
uh that stuff from what i can tell this
wasn't really
based on any historical chess games but
it was really interesting to see
that they picked this really really
dubious opening for beth
and showed that towns managed to to out
player uh in the opening
now i'm not going to spoil how this game
ends but maybe you can guess based on
you know beth being really good at chess
but i thought this game was really cool
to see uh because i think it
probably helped develop beth's opening
play quite a bit
by the end of this tournament she's
actually playing some really strong
chess players
and this type of opening play i don't
think would cut it
against the the player she's playing by
the end of the tournament
so perhaps this was her lesson to start
treating these guys seriously
no more dubious opening gambits you have
to actually
play some good chess with that though
let's try to take a look at why white's
position is so good here
well going back to this move bishop g4
which i said was sort of a mistake
i think that is pretty much revealed by
white's potential move of h3 now this
isn't shown
in uh the show and i don't believe it
was played in the game
but why is this move so strong well
rather than having this pawn defended
simply with the bishop on d6
this pawn is only indirectly defended
because this knight is immobilized for
the moment
now what this means is that if this
bishop were to move away white would be
able to take this pawn for free
and probably should also if the bishop
retreats
in this direction keeping the pin white
would have the option to play something
like g4
and still take this pawn on e5
so h3 essentially essentially forces
beth to capture on f3
and now after queen takes f3 we see that
white is almost entirely developed and
black is going to have to waste more
time
guarding these weaknesses on the queen
side just for an example line something
like queen d7
king side castles by white bishop d6 d3
and it's clear to see that white has no
trouble in the opening
getting fully developed and in the
meantime
uh black is just down upon and has a
worse structure
so really interesting to see those
opening choices there
now at the end of her first tournament i
do want to
show you guys at least this last game
from the
the beginning part of the series we
have beth harmon squaring off against
uh tournament favorite harry
beltic who is not a real chess player i
think most of the chess players they
show
uh i think all of the characters in the
series are fictional chess players
although some of them are loosely based
on real ones and they do actually
mention
real chess players they just don't show
them but harry beltic
uh basically what i'm trying to say not
a real chess player just a
chess player in the show as is beth
harmon but in the show they sort of
build them up
to be the favorite at beth's first
tournament uh super strong guy
really good at chess but let's see how
this goes for him
and by the way this one is also based on
a real-life chess game so for those of
you in the chat who think you you know
the good stuff here
go ahead and tell me who you think these
players are i would be very surprised if
anybody actually recognized this game
i think and if anybody gets it in the
chat they they've probably just looked
it up
although it is not an unknown game uh
okay
here we have beth playing with the white
pieces again and starting with
e4 she sort of does this throughout
almost the entire series
without spoiling anything and beltic
responds with the keracon so we've seen
this before
from the sturdy mr grants who got
absolutely slaughtered
richard reddy style now in the game
rather than play d4 as we've seen beth
play before
she actually adopts the two knights
variation of the cairo khan
and this is a little bit different than
playing the move 2 to d4
the difference is here is that when
white hasn't committed to this move
if black were to try to follow similar
paths
to what is normally played we actually
see
that white is perhaps able to make use
of this extra tempo
by playing knight e5 right this normally
would not be available to white because
white would have spent a turn
playing the move pawn to d4 and here
it's sort of thought that white does
actually get a good advantage because 95
is quite
quite strong for example if white were
to play something like d4 or had played
it earlier
black would have the opportunity to play
knight d7 preventing the move knight e5
so with the two knights black sort of
really shouldn't go for this main
variation stuff with d takes e4 and
bishop f5 d takes e4 is a
playable move for other reasons but not
with bishop f5 and instead we see baltic
adopting bishop g4 which is actually the
most common move
in this variation uh beth continues out
with h3
and we actually see black happy to give
up this bishop early on
in order for simple play as often
happens in the cara
now black plays e6 still keeping things
solid and
beth adopts a bit of a sideline with the
move g3
sort of just conservatively developing
the bishop out and castling the king
we see baltic playing g6 now which is
still perfectly fine
if not a little bit uh rare bishop g2
is perfectly normal bishop g7 we see
kingside castles
black gets developed with knight d7 and
now queen
backed e2 so this is a pretty strange
looking move
by beth harmon uh but it comes with
actually a very distinct and very
clear threat so who in the chat room
thinks they understand what this move
queen e2 is all about
why queen e2
and yeah people in the chat already do
have uh
do have the player with the white pieces
here
uh and so you guys are seeing the
surface level idea you guys are noticing
the surface level idea
but the idea is actually a bit deeper
than that
so i believe that harry beltic in the
show and
one uh just to spoil who actually is
playing this game
one kasparian in real life uh did notice
the threat
of taking on d5 if black does nothing
white is going to take on d5
use this pin on the black king and win a
pawn
for free and so having noticed this
threat both beltick
and kasparian in real life play the move
d4
locking down the center but we'll see
that this is perhaps
a slight opening in accuracy and it's
really interesting to talk about
why so who sees sort of the deeper plan
behind queen e2 it's not just about
taking on d5
what is white's plan beyond taking on d5
and yeah both albert and gerardo in the
chat have the idea
it's actually to give this f pawn some
mobility
this is a really common plan for white
in this type of structure
you see an early fianchetto of the
bishop and this bishop does a lot of
good things
but one main thing is it's a great
defender of the king
and this allows white a little bit more
freedom to start pushing these pawns in
front of her own king
so with this bishop here easily
defending the king
white is looking to do some kind of
kingside pawn expansion beth is looking
to to play for activity now for this
reason the most common move here in the
best move is actually knight to e7
black should deal with this threat to
the d pawn but should not do so
by closing down the center and let's try
to understand why
first of all in the game we see d4 in
the slightly strange looking move
knight b1 is actually perfectly fine for
beth
she does take a step back but with the
center closing down
time is actually not all that important
when things are moving very very rapidly
the center is open there are weaknesses
everywhere the king is in danger
then you do have to be worried about
these this type of retreating move
but with the center closed meaning these
pawns aren't going anywhere they're
pretty much locked into place
then you can afford to waste a little
bit more time
so center being closed we see hairy
baltic
developing out with 97 but now f4 is
actually really really comfortable
for beth by playing d4 and locking down
the center
it is actually much much easier to play
a move like f4 and to go for this type
of plan
with the center being totally locked up
now for comparison let's take a look at
the move
knight e7 let's say white still plays
this move of d3
black goes ahead and castles and white
plays this move of
f4 now first and foremost
white's plan is still sort of going
along rather swimmingly
but already you can see that white is
lacking some of the threats that she has
in the other position here there's no
threat to capture a pawn on e5
because black has kept things a lot more
solid
also very importantly this bishop is not
locked out of the game yet
and black is you know sort of keeping
with the cairo mindset a bit more
rigidly here
keeping things safe staying solid not
making any weaknesses
now from here the game could go in many
different directions but even
f5 is an available choice for black
and in this case yes the center is going
to get locked down
but black is at least with some
breathing room in this case with this f
pawn here
also playable are queen side expansion
ideas with something like b5
a5 uh and even a simple move like queen
c7
just keeping things sort of in flux is
perfectly fine
now let's go back to the game so in the
game we see this pawn come to d4 the
knight come to b1
e5 d3 97 and pawn out
to f4 uh harry beltek continues with
queen c7 and now we see a really
interesting move of
a4 and this is a pretty classy move by
beth harmon if i do say so myself
gone are the days of you know zero
positional understanding
a4 is a really smart move in this
position
i think many chess players myself
included would be very tempted to
develop this knight and go immediately
for a push on the king's side but
conversely black is not going to be
sitting around
doing nothing black is going to look to
expand on the queen side
and find counter play on this side of
the board so the move a4
is actually a really mature chess move
in the sense that it recognizes
that white's plan isn't everything it's
also useful to slow down your opponent's
plan and that's what beth is doing here
against harry's plan of expanding on the
king's side
harry goes ahead and castles kingside
still half to castle even with the
closed center
and now we see that beth is already
breaking through with the move of f5
something that
definitely wouldn't be happening just
yet had harry left these pawns
guarding these light squares now
feeling a bit desperate perhaps harry
actually plays the move
f6 and this is a pretty sad move to make
for black
why is it so sad well you don't want to
allow white to ever get this pawn to f6
shutting out this bishop entirely so you
want to play it yourself
to stop white from doing this now
unfortunately though
this does also have the effect of
shutting out your bishop entirely for
the moment
and more importantly as always when you
move an f pawn
it weakens the light squares on the
king's side and we do see beth
look to take advantage of this the
immediate f takes g6 doesn't really
accomplish anything there's no reason to
rush for this
so beth brings the knight back into the
game with knight d2
we see harry aiming to activate this
bishop that he just treated so poorly by
playing f6
now the slow move king h2 actually
appears in the game
and this one is rather deep but i think
the the opening struggle
is sort of coming to a close here white
is definitely on the better side
with the more active plan in the faster
plan on the king's side
and we see that in the game f takes g6
knight f3
trade of the bishops and
now things actually complicate a little
bit and beth really shows
that she's a true professional by this
point already at the end of her first
tournament
she's playing on both sides of the board
not uh you know getting tunnel vision
against with this attack against the
white king also playing in the center
playing on the c file and uh just sort
of totally outclassing her opponent in
this game
now again i don't think i want to spoil
too much and show you guys the ending
although actually no for this game i
already showed you guys the result
so you know who cares let's see it all
uh black plays knight b3
in order to bring the knight off of an
undefended square
we see black now desperately trying to
support the weakened pawn
on d4 beth plays knight h4 which is a
really interesting move
to actually give this bishop a path into
the game we see queen c8 and then beth
achieves just that with bishop f3 to g4
the queen jumps back to f7
and the knight having gotten out of the
way retreats back
to f3 now queen g8 steps out of a threat
that beth had made on the f file h4
played in the game aiming to further
break down the remaining defenders in
front of the black king
king g7 and now beth simply doubles on
the f file
doubles the rooks increasing the
pressure rook back to d8
harry beltic is just passing the time at
this point life is already pretty tough
for the black pieces
queen c2 is a move to add a little bit
of pressure to this knight
we see b6 in the game now h5 as i said
looking to remove the final defenders in
front of black's king
c5 played in the game we do take this
pawn off the board
and now the tactics start to fly c4
d4 played in the game black temporarily
is able to win a center pawn
but now after e5 things get a little bit
crazy
f5 played in the game um
notably this pawn is pinned so you can't
do anything like take here
there are other options here for black
like czech or queen d5
but we'll stick with f5 because it's
rather complicated bishop takes f5
now queen d5 played in the game and beth
comes up with the interesting move
of bishop 2e6 and here
interestingly very interestingly very
very interestingly
beth sort of declares victory she says
like come on dude
what are we doing here what are we doing
here
we we both know what's going on okay we
both
get it uh but harry you know always a
fighter wants to play the move
rook h8 check and this is one of those
moments that i did want to sort of
critique
again they did a fantastic job with
almost all the dialogue and almost all
of the chess
but here they they had a line that
didn't really make much sense
uh beth says something like this doesn't
make a difference i'll just cover it
with the bishop
i don't have to use the queen and to be
honest with you
she's right about covering the check
with the bishop this is what should be
done
in order to avoid getting checkmated but
i really don't see how the queen could
be used here
so she doesn't have to use the queen she
also can't use the queen
and that didn't really make sense to me
but really small thing
i wanted to mention we see bishop h3
instead
now knight takes g6 played in the game
and this is actually the
losing move for harry despite beth sort
of already declaring victory
there is one move to keep black in the
game here and that is the
strange-looking
rook to d3 what's the point of this move
well the point is simply
to remove this queen's access
to the king side keep this queen boxed
out
and then black is able to survive
perhaps
instead though we see the move knight
takes g6
and this is a pretty reasonable mistake
to make
beth continues now with the rook f7
check king h6
and then if you want to try and find a
really stellar tactic for yourself at
home go ahead and pause the video here
because this is a really really cool one
that beth harmon unleashes
but uh all right here it is the winning
combination
is queen takes g6
now in the actual chess game i believe
they play it through to checkmate
uh and that is the idea of queen takes
g6 there's just a combination that leads
to checkmate
with king takes rook 1 to f6 check king
g5
rook f5 check king g6 rook 7
to f6 check so a little bit of a funny
dance with the rooks to force the king
back to the g
file uh king h7 now we get the check
in the check and with the rooks in
perfect position
we now get a very beautiful bishop f5
mate
and this king is totally totally stuck
with a checkmate and so that is the game
uh between
one rashid nezhmetanov against kasparian
but in the show it is beth harmon
against
beltic and i do have one more thing to
say to you show runners here i did find
a mistake
i went sort of frame by frame to make
sure i was getting all the positions
right
so after queen takes g6 black actually
resigns
but seemingly magically when they cut
back to the chessboard
harry's king is on g7 the queen is still
on g6
and this rook on f7 has disappeared so i
don't know what happened there i don't
know if originally they had
you know some other combination that
they were shooting on the chessboard
but there is some funny stuff going on
when harry resigns he tips his king over
and the king was was seemingly on g7
with the rook on f7 missing so some
strange stuff you know they did a good
job but
got to work a little bit harder to get
one by me
uh that being said though really cool
games from the show
and like i said these games all appear
in the first two episodes like there is
so much more
to the entire show uh i want to say that
uh i did get i think some information on
this last game
uh i didn't do the research myself to
figure out which game this was i
actually used
gotham chess's video who has a and
really cool hour-long video
on it and i think he got some insider
info from like the show runners and
stuff
so if you do want to check out more of
the queen's gambits games
uh he does a lot of the later games as
well in his video
but that is going to conclude my
coverage of beth harmon
i don't know if i'll do another class on
beth let me know if this is something
you guys enjoyed it's a little bit
different from my normal classes
but i had a lot of fun you know sort of
going frame by frame in this netflix
show looking for mistakes in cool little
easter eggs
hopefully you enjoyed it as well if
you're watching live please stay tuned
on the
on the twitch channel actually we're
going to be going live with tactics time
uh uh but if you've had enough chess for
the night or if you're watching the
youtube version i want to thank you very
much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will see you next time
you